the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay let's go so if you want to know the
subject of today's class its ax equal B
I got started writing down different
possibilities for ax equal B and I got
carried away
there's it just appears all over the
place and the four different sizes
different ranks different situations
nearly singular not nearly singular and
the question is what do you do in each
case so can I outline my little two
pages of notes here and then pick on one
or two of these topics to develop today
and a little more on Friday about
gram-schmidt so I won't do much of much
if any of gram-schmidt today but I will
do the others okay
so the problem is ax equal B that
problem has come from somewhere we have
to produce some kind of an answer X okay
so I'm sort of going from good to bad or
good or easy to difficult in this list
so well except for number zero which is
an answer in all cases the using the
pseudo-inverse that I introduced last
time so that deals with zero eigenvalues
and zero singular values by saying
they're inverse is also 0 which is kind
of wild so we'll come back to the
meaning of the pseudo inverse but now
I'm I want to get real here about
different situations so number one is
the good normal case when a person has a
square matrix of reasonable size
reasonable condition the condition
number o the condition number I should
call it Sigma one
over Sigma n it's a ratio of the largest
to the smallest singular value and let's
say that's within reason not more than a
thousand or something then normal
ordinary elimination is going to work
and MATLAB the command that would
produce the answer is just backslash but
so this is the normal case now in cases
that follow or have problems of some
kind and I guess I'm hoping that this is
a sort of useful dictionary of what to
do for for you and me both okay so we
have this case here where we have too
many equations so it's a pretty normal
case and it's the we'll think mostly of
solving by least squares which leads us
to the normal equation so this is
standard happens all the time in
statistics and I'm thinking in the
reasonable case so that's that would be
X hat the solution a transfer this this
matrix would be invertible and
reasonable size so we could actually
backslash would still solve that problem
backslash doesn't require a square
matrix to give you an answer so that's
that's the good case where you would
just the matrix is not too big so it's
not unreasonable to to form a transpose
a okay now there is the other extreme
and like what's exciting for us is so
this is the underdetermined case I don't
have enough equations so I have to put
something more in to get a specific
answer and what makes it exciting for us
is that that's typical of deep learning
there are so many weights in a deep
neural network that the weights would be
the unknowns
it wouldn't be necessarily linear
wouldn't be linear but still the idea is
the same that we we have many solutions
and we have to pick one or we have to
pick an algorithm and then it will find
one and so we could pick the minimum
norm solution the shortest solution that
would be an l2 answer or we could go to
l1 and a big question that's I think
might be settled in 2018 is does deep
learning and the iteration from
stochastic gradient descent that we'll
see soon pretty soon does it go to the
minimum L what does it pick out an l1
solution that that's really like an
exciting math question you know for a
long time it was sort of standard to say
these deep learning AI codes are
fantastic but what are they doing we
don't know
you know the interior but where we when
I say we I don't mean I other people are
getting there and I'm gonna tell you as
much as I can about it when we get there
okay so that's those are pretty standard
cases M equals N and greater than them M
less than n but not crazy okay now let
me the second board will have like more
difficult problems where usually because
they're nearly singular in some way the
columns are nearly dependent okay so
look for that would be the columns in
bad condition you just picked a terrible
basis or nature did or somehow you've
got a matrix a whose columns are
virtually dependent almost linearly
dependent the inverse matrix is really
but it exists then that's when you you
go in and you fix the columns you
orthogonalize columns instead of
accepting the columns a 1 a 2 up to a n
of the given matrix you go in and you
find orthonormal column vectors in that
column space an orthonormal basis Q 1 to
Q n and the two are connected by
gram-schmidt and the famous matrix
statement of gram-schmidt is here are
the columns of a here are the columns of
Q and there's a triangular matrix that
connects the two so that is a central
topic gram-schmidt in that idea of
orthogonal Ising it just appears
everywhere pairs all over course six in
many many situations with different
names so that I'm sort of saving a
little bit till next time and let me
tell you why because just the
organization of gram-schmidt is
interesting so gram-schmidt you could do
the normal way so that's what I teach in
1806 just just take every column as it
comes subtract off projections onto
their previous stuff get it orthogonal
to the previous guys normalize it to be
a unit vector then you've got that
column go on sorry say that again and
then I'll say it again two days from now
so gram-schmidt the idea is you take the
columns you you say the second column is
some common second orthogonal vector Q 2
will be some combination of columns one
and two orthogonal to the first ya
what's lust to do and and there's
another order which is really
the better order to do gram-schmidt and
it allows you to do column pivoting so
this is my topic for next time to see
gram-schmidt more carefully right
okay yeah column pivoting means you
allow yourself to take the you the
columns might not come in a good order
so you allow yourself to reorder them we
know that you have to do that for
elimination right and in the elimination
it would be rows so elimination we would
have a the matrix a and its we take the
first row as the first pivot row and
then the second row and then the third
row but if the pivot is so that if the
pivot is too small and reorder the rows
so it's it's its row ordering that comes
up in elimination and you well MATLAB
just systematically says okay that's the
pivot that's coming up the third pivot
comes up out of the third row but MATLAB
says look down that whole third column
for a better pivot a bigger pivot switch
do we do a row exchange so there are
lots of permutations then you end up
with a something there that permutes the
rows and then that gets factored into
Leu so I'm saying something that about
elimination that that just sort of side
comment that you you would never do
elimination without considering the
possibility of row exchanges and then
this is
gram-schmidt orthogonalization so this
is the Lu world here's the QR world and
here it happens to be columns that
you're commuting so that's coming that
this is section 2.2 but there's more a
2.2 has quite a bit in it including
number 0 the pseudo-inverse and
including some of these things actually
this will be also in 2.0 and maybe this
is what I'm like saying more about today
so this would be a put a little star for
today here what do you do so this is a
case where the matrix is nearly singular
you're you're in danger its inverse is
gonna be big unreasonably big and I
wrote inverse problems there because
inverse problem is that's a type of
problem that you need application that
you often need to solve or that you the
engineering and and science have to
solve
so I'll just say a little more about
that but that's a typical application in
which you get your near singular your
matrix isn't good enough to invert well
of course you could over say well I'll
just use the pseudo inverse but that's
numerically that's like cheating you've
got a you got to get in there and do
something about it
so inverse problems would be examples
actually as I write that I think that
would be a topic that I should add that
to the list of potential topics for a
for a three week project to look up a
book on inverse problems so what do I
mean by the inverse problem I'll just
finish this thought where of what's an
inverse problem typically you you you
know about their system say a network
like trying to
RLC Network and you give it a voltage or
a current you give it an input and you
find the output you find out what
current flows what the voltages are but
inverse problems are suppose you know
the response to different voltages what
were the what was the network you see
that the problem let me say it again
discover what the network is from its
outputs so that turns out to typically
be a problem that gives nearly singular
matrices that's that's a difficult
problem you sort of near a lot of nearby
networks would give virtually the same
output so so you have a matrix that's
nearly singular it's got singular values
very close to zero what do you do then
well the world of inverse problems
thinks of adding a penalty term some
kind of a penalty term when I minimize
this thing just by itself in the usual
way a transpose a has a giant inverse
the matrix a is badly conditioned it
takes vectors Verge almost to zero so
that a transpose a is has got a giant
inverse and you're you're at risk of
losing everything to roundoff so you
this is the solution you could call it a
kind of cheap solution but it's
everybody uses it so I won't put that
word on videotape but that that sort of
resolves a problem but then the question
it it shifts a problem anyway - what
number what should be the penalty how
much should you penalize it you see as
you as you buy adding that
you're gonna make it invertible and if
you make this bigger and bigger and
bigger it's more and more well
conditioned it resolves the trouble here
and I'm so this is like today I'm gonna
do more with that so that I'll stop
there and pick it up after saying
something about 6 & 7
I hope this is helpful it was helpful to
me certainly to to see all these
possibilities and to write down sort of
what you what the symptom is it's like a
doctor like a linear equation doctor
like you look for the symptoms and then
you propose some some something at CVS
that works or it doesn't work but you do
something about it okay so so when the
problem is too big so up to now the
problems have not been giant out of
course it's so but now when it's too big
well maybe it's still in Corbett really
big then this is in 2.1 so that's to
come back to the word I could have
written in here if I was just gonna
write one word would be interation
iterative methods meaning you take a
step like well conjugate gradient method
is the is the hero of iterative methods
and then there that name I raced is
Krylov and there are other names
associated with iterative methods so
that's the section that we passed over
just just to get rolling but we'll come
back to so then that that one you never
get the exact answer but you get closer
and closer
if the iterative method is successful
like conjugate gradients you get
pretty close pretty fast and then you
say okay I'll take it
and then finally way too big like no
we're not in core just your matrix you
just have a giant giant problem which of
course is happening these days and then
one way to do it is your matrix you I
mean you you can't even look at the
matrix a much less a transpose a
transpose a would be like unthinkable
you couldn't do it in in the in the in a
year so randomized linear algebra has
popped up and that the idea there which
will see is to use probability to sample
the matrix and work with your samples so
if the matrix is reasonably it is not is
too way too big but not too crazy so to
speak then you could sample the columns
and the rows and get a an answer from
the sample see if I sample the columns
of a matrix I'm getting something so
said what is sampling mean let me just
complete this say say add add a little
to this sample of matrix so I have a
giant matrix a might be sparse of course
I didn't distinguish over there sparse
things that would be another thing so if
I just take a random X random X's more
than one but not the full n dimensions
those will give me random guys in the
column space and if the matrix is kind
of reasonable those will give me it
won't take too many to have a pretty
reasonable I
of what that column space is like and
and with its right-hand side so so this
world of randomized linear algebra has
grown because it had to and of course
you any statement it can never say for
sure you're gonna get the right answer
but but but so using the inequalities of
probability you can often say that
you're the chance of being way off is
you know less than one in two to the 20s
or something so so the answer is in
reality you you get that you get a good
answer okay that is like the end of this
chapter two point four so here this is
all chapter two really the the iterative
methods in to one all that most of this
is in two point two big is two point
three and then really big is randomized
in two point four okay so now where are
we
you're going to let me know or not if
this is useful the C but you're sort of
you sort of see what what are real-life
problems and of course we're highly
especially interested in getting to the
deep learning examples which are
underdetermined yeah then when you're
under determined you've got many
solutions and the question is which one
is a good one and in deep learning I
just I can't resist saying another word
you hope so there are many solutions
what to do well your your pick some
algorithm like steepest descent which is
going to find a solution so you're like
you hope it's a good one and what is a
good one mean verses are not good one
they're all solutions a good one means
that when you apply it to the test
data that you haven't yet seen it gives
good results on the test data you've
really the solution has learned
something from the training data and it
works on the test data so that's the the
the big question in deep learning how
does it happen that you by doing
gradient descent or whatever algorithm
how does that algorithm sort of bias the
solution it's called implicit bias how
does that algorithm bias a solution
toward one toward a solution that's that
generalizes that works on test data and
you can think of algorithms which would
give it approach a solution that did not
work on test data so that's what you
want to stay away from you want the ones
that work so there's very deep math
questions there which are kind of knew
they didn't arise until they did and
will try to save some of what's what's
being understood okay can I focus now on
for the rest the rest of today on this
case when the matrix is nearly singular
so you could apply elimination but it
would give a poor result but so the then
one solution is well yeah
one solution is the SVD I only mentioned
the SVD here as an algorithm but of
course it is the SVD would give you
gives you gives you an answer boy where
should that have gone well space over
here the SVD so that produces you you
have a equal u Sigma V transpose and
then a inverse is V Sigma inverse u
transpose okay
so we're in the case here we're talking
about number five nearly singular where
Sigma has some very small singular
values then Sigma inverse has some very
big singular values so this is you're
really in kind of wild wild territory
here with with very big inverses so that
would that would be one way to do it but
this is a this is a way to regularize
the problem so let's just pay attention
to that okay okay so suppose I minimize
the sum of ax minus B squared and Delta
squared times the size of x squared and
I'm going to use the l2 norm it's gonna
be at least squares a peanut least
squares with penalty so of course it's
the l2 norm here - yep okay suppose I
solve that for a delta for some I choose
I have to choose a delta a positive
Delta and when I choose a positive Delta
then I have a solvable problem
even if this goes to zero or a does
crazy things this is going to keep me
away from singular in fact what equation
does that lead to so that's a least
squares problem with an extra penalty
term so it would come I suppose let's
see if I write the equations a delta I x
equals B 0 maybe that is the least
squares equation the usual normal
equation for this
augmented system because what's the
error here this is the new big a a star
let's say X equals this is the new B so
if I apply least-squares to that what do
I do I minimize the sum of squares and I
so I'm in so least squares would
minimize ax minus B squared that would
be the from the first components and
Delta squared x squared from the last
component which is exactly what we said
we were doing so in a way this is the
equation that saw that the penalty
method is solving and the question is so
one question natural is watch what's
your Delta B well that's that questions
beyond us today that it's it's a balance
of how what you can believe and how much
noise is in the system and everything
yeah choice of Delta what we could ask
is the math question what happens as
Delta goes to 0 so suppose I solve this
problem let's see I could write it
differently shall I write there what
would be the equation here this part
would give us the a transpose a and then
this part would give us just the
identity x equals a transpose B I think
yeah wouldn't that be so really I've
written here what that is is a star
transpose a star that this is least
squares on this gives it gives that
equation so all of those are equivalent
all of those would be equivalent
statements of what the penalized problem
is that you're solving and then the
question is as Delta goes to 0 what
happens of course something you're when
Delta goes to 0 you're you're falling
off the cliff something something quite
different it's suddenly going to happen
there maybe we could even understand
this this question with a 1 by 1 matrix
yeah I think this section starts with a
1 by 1 suppose a is just a number okay
maybe I'll just put that on this board
here suppose a is just a number so what
am I gonna call that number just one by
one let me call it Sigma because it's
certainly the leading singular value
okay so so what's my equation that I'm
solving a transpose a would be Sigma
square plus Delta square one by one X
should I give some subscript here I
should really to do it right this is the
solution for a given Delta and I'm
asking what happened so that solution
will exist fine this matrix is certainly
invertible that's positive semi definite
at least that's positive semi definite
and what about delta squared i it is
positive definite of course just the
identity with a factor so this is a
positive definite matrix it's there i
certainly have a solution and let me
keep going on this one by one case this
would be a transfer a is just a sigma i
think it's just sigma p okay so this is
a is one by one and there are two cases
here sigma bigger than zero or sigma
equals zero
and in either case we I just want to
know what's the limit so so the answer X
yeah let me just take the right hand
side
no that's fine yep okay so am i
competing okay the using the penalized
thing on a one by one problem which you
could say is kind of a little bit small
for so solving this equation or
equivalently minimizing this so I'm I'm
here I'm finding the minimum of a was
Sigma X minus B squared plus Delta
squared x squared I'm because I'm hoping
that if I found that you see it's just
one by one just a number and I'm hoping
that if calculate calculus will agree
with linear algebra here that if I find
the minimum of this so let me write it
out Sigma squared x squared and Delta
squared x squared and then minus 2 Sigma
X B and then plus B squared and now I'm
going to find the minimum which means
I'd set the derivative to 0 so I get 2
Sigma squared and 2 Delta squared I get
a 2 here and this gives me the X
derivative is 2 Sigma B so I get a 2
there and I'm ok I just cancelled both
the twos and that's the equation so I
can solve that equation X is Sigma B
Sigma over Sigma squared plus Delta
squared B so it's really that quantity I
want to let Delta go to 0 so again what
am I doing here I'm taking a 1 by 1
example just to see what happens in the
limit
as sigma-delta sorry Delta goes to 0
what happens so I just have to look at
that what is the limit of that thing in
a circle as Delta goes to 0 that's so
I'm finding out for a one by one problem
what a penalized least squares problem
Ridge regression could all over the
place what happens ok so what happens to
that number as Delta goes to 0 1 over
Sigma so now the Delta go to 0 so that
approaches 1 over Sigma right because
Delta disappears and Sigma over Sigma
squared 1 over Sigma so it approaches
the inverse but but what's the other
possibility here the other possibility
is that Sigma is 0
I didn't say whether this matrix is 1 by
1 matrix was invertible or not if Sigma
is not 0 then I go to 1 over Sigma if
Sigma is really small it'll take a while
Delta will have to get small small small
even compared to Sigma until till
finally that term goes away and I'm just
have 1 over Sigma but what if Sigma is 0
sorry to get excited about 0 who would
get excited about 0 ok so this is the
case when this is 1 over Sigma if Sigma
is positive and what does it approach if
Sigma is 0 0 because this is 0 it will
the whole problem was like disappeared
here the Sigma was 0 here's a Sigma so
anyway
Sigma will be if Sigma is 0 and I'm
getting 0 all the time but I have a
decent problem because the del
- squared is there I have a decent
problem until the last minute my problem
falls apart Delta goes to 0 and I have a
zero equals zero problem I'm lost but
the point is the penalty kept me
positive kept me with this Delta squared
term until the last critical moment even
it kept me positive even if that was
zero if that is zero and this is zero I
still have something here so I still
have a problem to solve and what's the
limit then so a 1 over Sigma if Sigma is
positive and what's the answer if Sigma
is not positive it's 0 just tell me it's
again I'm getting 0 well I get 0 all the
way and I get 0 in the limit and now let
me just ask what have I got here what
what is this this sudden bifurcation
that's what's the do I recognize this
the the inverse in the limit as Delta
goes to 0 is either 1 over Sigma if it's
if that makes sense
or at 0 which is not like 1 over segment
1 over Sigma as Sigma goes to 0 the
thing this thing is getting bigger and
bigger
but at Sigma equals 0 its 0 you see
that's a really that's a strange kind of
a limit and what word now it would be
over there what have I found here in
this limit you say say it again because
it was exactly right there's
pseudo-inverse so this this this system
choose Delta greater than zero then
Delta are going to 0 the solution goes
to the pseudo-inverse
that's the key fact that that is when
Delta is really really small then this
behaves in a pretty crazy way if Delta
is really really small then and then
Sigma is bigger or it's zero if it's
bigger you go this way if it's zero you
go that way so that's that's the message
and that this there's penalized these
squares approaches as the penalty gets
smaller and smaller approaches the
correct answer the always correct answer
with that sudden split between zero and
not zero that we associate with the
pseudo-inverse yeah of course in a
practical case you're trying to find the
the resistances and inductances in a
circuit by trying the circuit and
looking at the output B and figuring out
what input what what the so the unknown
X is the is the unknown system
parameters the voltage and not the
voltage and current but the but the
resistance and inductance and
capacitance okay so that's now I've only
proved that in the one by one case you
may say that's not much of a proof in
the one by one case we could see it
happen in front of our eyes
so really step I haven't taken here is
to complete that to any matrix a so
that's the statement then that's the
statement
so that's the statement for any or any
matrix a this matrix a transpose A plus
Delta squared inverse times a transpose
that's the solution matrix to our
problem right yep that's what I wrote
down up there I take the inverse and pop
it over there that approaches a plus the
pseudo inverse and that's what we just
checked for one by one one by one this
was Sigma over Sigma squared plus Delta
squared and it went to either to 1 over
Sigma or to 0 it split in the limit it
shows that limits are can be delicate
you know the limit as Delta goes to 0
this thing it suddenly discontinuous
it's it's it's this number that's
growing and then suddenly at 0 it falls
back to 0 anyway that would be the
statement actually statisticians
discovered the pseudo inverse like
independently of linear algebra history
of it because statisticians did exactly
that to regularize the problem they
introduced a penalty and worked with
this matrix so so statisticians were the
first to see that that yeah to think of
that as a natural thing to do in in a
practical case at a penalty okay so I
guess so this is adding a penalty but
remember that we stayed with L two norms
staying with l2 least-squares we could
ask what happens yeah
suppose the penalty is the l1 norm
suppose I minimize I'm not up to do this
today
suppose I minimize that maybe let's say
I'll do l2 but I'll do the penalty guy
in the l1 norm I guess I'm not yeah I'm
certainly not an expert on that or you
could even think just that power so that
would have a name that statisticians a
statistician invented this it's called
the lasso in the l1 norm and it's a big
deal snow decisions like the l1 norm
because because it really because it
gives sparse solutions it gives you give
sort of more genuine solutions without a
whole lot of little little components in
the answer yep so that this was an
important step and so maybe let me just
say again we're where we are in that big
list the the the the two important ones
that I haven't done yet are these
iterative methods in 2.1 so that's like
conventional linear algebra just how to
deal with a big matrix maybe with some
special structure that's what linear
algebra is numerical linear algebra is
all about and then gram-schmidt with or
without pivoting which is a workhorse of
of numerical computing and I think I
better save that for next time
so so this is the one
picked for this time and we saw what
happened in l2 well we saw it for one by
one would you want to extend to prove
this for any a going beyond one by one
how would you prove such a thing for any
a I guess I'm I'm not going to do it it
it's too painful but but how would you
do it you would use the SVD if you want
to prove something about matrices about
any matrix the SVD is the best thing you
could have the best tool you could have
I can write this in terms of the SVD I
just plug in I just plug in a equals
whatever the SVD tells me to put in
there you Sigma V transpose plug it in
there simplify it using the fact that
these are orthogonal you know I always
if I have any good luck it'll I'll get
an identity somewhere from there and an
identity somewhere from there and it'll
all simplify it'll all diagonalize
that's what the SVD really does this
turns my messy problem into a problem
about their diagonal matrix Sigma in the
middle so I might as well put Sigma in
the middle yeah why not before we give
up on it
a special case of that but the really
the genuine case would be when a is
Sigma Sigma transpose Sigma plus Delta
squared i inverse times Sigma transpose
approaches the pseudo inverse Sigma plus
and the point is the matrix Sigma here
is diagonal and oh I'm practically there
actually why am i close to being being
able to read this off well everything is
diagonal here diagonal diagonal diagonal
and what's happening on those diagonal
entries so you had to take my word that
when I plugged in the SVD the U and the
V kind of got got separated out to the
far left and the far right and it was
that that stayed in the middle so it's
really this is the heart of it and how
do you suppose so that's a diagonal
matrix so I'm just looking what happens
on each diagonal entry and which problem
is that well the the question of what's
happening on a typical diagonal entry of
this thing is is what question the
one-by-one case now one by one because
each entry in the diagonal is not even
noticing the others yeah so so that's
the logic and it would be in the notes
prove it first for one by one and
secondly for diagonal this and finally
for with A's and they're using the SVD
with you and be transposed to two to get
out of the way and bring us back to here
okay so that's the theory but really I I
guess I'm thinking that far the most
important thing message in today's
lecture is in this list of different
types of problems that appear and
different ways to work with them and we
haven't done gram-schmidt and that will
be and we haven't done it eration so
this is I'm kind of this chapter as a
survey of well more than a survey of
what numerical linear algebra is about
and I haven't done random yet I'm sorry
that's coming - so three pieces are
still to come but let's take the last
two minutes off and call it a day